Avoir, ce documentaire, comme
nous le dit Louis-Philippe
Ouimet.
♪ Let it be ♪
- L'enregistrement de l'album
"Let It Be" des Beatles avait
été filmé en janvier 1969 en
mode cinéma vérité. En 1970,
un documentaire de 80 minutes
avait vu le jour, mais 50 ans
plus tard, le réalisateur
Peter Jackson a sorti des voûtes
les 57 heures d'images pour en
faire un film de 6 heures qui
sortira à partir du 25 novembre.
♪ ♪ ♪
- La nouvelle bande-annonce est
à couper le souffle, car voici
les Beatles comme vous ne
♪ ♪ ♪
- La nouvelle bande-annonce est
à couper le souffle, car voici
les Beatles comme vous ne
les avez jamais entendus ou vus.
En gros plan, on assiste à leur
processus de création comme si
on était en studio avec eux.
Et oui, ils se disputent.
On entend Paul McCartney
s'exclamer que dans 50 ans,
on dira que le groupe s'est
séparé parce que Yoko Ono s'est
assise sur un amplificateur.
PIERRE MARCHAND, Producteur
et fan des Beatles
- Je pense que la beauté du film
de Peter Jackson, du nouveau
documentaire qui va s'appeler
"Get back", c'est qu'il va nous
montrer justement tout
l'autre côté qu'on avait
jamais vu, le côté harmonie,
le côté amitité entre les gars,
le côté synergie
de ces 4 gars en studio.
♪ Don't let me down ♪
- En attendant le film,
c'est la fête pour les fans
des Beatles puisque demain,
vendredi, sortira la réédition
de "Let It Be". Dans la version
super deluxe, on retrouvera bien
sûr l'album original remixé
par Giles Martin, mais aussi
un album de 27 prises inédites
et puis le fameux mix de
Glyn John qui n'était
pas sorti à l'époque.
- Je trouve doublement génial,
c'est qu'on va avoir le vrai mix
que les Beatles voulait pour
"Let It be". Qui est
de Glyn John qui est pas
de Phil Spector. Phil Spector,
c'est l'album que McCartney
déteste encore aujourd'hui et
d'avoir le vrai album d'époque,
qu'il aurait voulu lancer,
on l'a jamais eu, c'est la
première fois qu'on va l'avoir
donc ça je trouve
ça doublement intéressant.
- Et comme si ce n'était pas
assez, il y aussi la sortie
cette semaine, "The Beatles Get
back" le livre pour accompagner
le film. Visiblemement,
la machine marketing roule
à plein régime. Les fans
des Beatles devront casser
leur tire-lire.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Avec le splendide remixage
de l'album "Let It Be", avec
la sortie d'un nouveau livre
et avec ce film qui sera
disponible sur la Disney +,